today we remember the compassion we
showed to one another the resolve that
minnesota demonstrated to the world and
how in the face of unfathomable loss we
rose as one big mike
did not start his last game he came in
bailey over actually started that game
they did what uh known as the old
piggyback he followed him up and the big
right-handers first pitch is a fastball
ripped to left field
and cut off by cave so he makes a good
play holding wit to a single and whit
had been oh for his last 10.
and marifield gets caught halfway and he
will run into the tag
banana simply by holding the ball was
able to get mirrorfield who had thoughts
of stealing second base and in the end
only three men back they'll be facing
brady singer tonight brady is making his
fourth start against minnesota this year
and he got him with an elevated fastball
which has been an effective pitch for
him
one away one down and now here's buxton
they're already starting to scatter in
the restaurant in center field
high fly left center field headed to the
bullpen and gone
into the second deck
over the bullpen well we're going to
have to add another home run to that
chart that we just looked at because
that's got to be up there in the 440 450
range that ball was crushed as well and
second consecutive game with a home run
in the first inning get this crowd on
its feet good showing tonight and
brings a smile to everybody's faces
that's what you came to see right there
this ball ran right back to the middle
almost identical to the pitch that
merrifield
hit the first pitch of the game leading
off this time
not a single but a home run from buxton
and he knew it immediately
he opens the scoring one-nothing twins
as polanco batting left-handed easy
night at the yard is this ball tattoo
deep right field for polanco and back to
back it's two-nothing twins
jorge polanco turned and burned into
right field number 28 for polanco
well we've seen this consistently from
him for the last few months i mean he's
been a power threat that
maybe he didn't expect leading this team
in home runs i mean it's been incredible
to watch what he's been able to do
closing in on that switch hitting home
run record for the twins and he does
that so well from the left side he knows
exactly what balls he can turn on
donaldson hit his 22nd in the first
inning last night
donaldson loses his bat which he doesn't
care about right now after a three-pitch
strikeout so strikeout home run home run
strikeout to begin brady singer's night
the lead-off man for the twins nick
gordon here in the second inning
a drive right center field and tag
for the scoreboard and gone
off the facing of the second deck nick
gordon with two home runs and they've
both been tape measure shots against the
royals yeah he got the head out on this
ball got himself a little hanging slider
and
he didn't miss it that smile on his face
that's a
guy taking advantage of an opportunity
of starting it first started
his career at shortstop and here
my goodness that was a rocket
it was his first
chance to for a put out
well he's put out on three pitches
minnesota adds another home run they
lead three nothing
and now hanser alberto
and there's a base hit into left field
a swinging mission down to an e
goes dozier as he strikes out for the
second half of the inning and the first
strikeout for pineda in the ball game
thought i was working hard but i wasn't
doing what jim was doing
great stop at third arise comes up
firing what a play
luis arise taking a double away from
merrifield a phenomenal play to end the
ending nikki lopez flight out to left
field in the first inning
there you go there's a base hit into
right field
that's it so that extends his hitting
streak to eight
and is on base streak to 21 in a row
three nothing minnesota three infielders
on the left side salvia is hit in the
left hip and so the royals have it first
and second with nobody down that pitch
ran in on salvia just got him in the
left hip prevented tendy who grounded
his second his first time up
and a line drive is into center field
nikki lopez is going to come home on
buxton
the throw was cut off by cenote
and the royals are on the board
and ben and tendy drives in another run
that is his 13th on this trip got the
pitch he was looking for look whatever
that is that's center right middle of
the dish
and hitting a perfect spot umpire
doesn't have a glove he can't make a
play nikki lopez had to freeze watch him
he freezes momentum just a minute
because he don't want to get doubled up
there's nobody out head's a heady play
turns on the burners
max kepler will lead off kept flew out
to left field he's only at bat 16 homers
46 driven in on the year
fly ball right field and
go
there's the one
and that's how you answer another two
strike home run from the twins
four good swings now today this one the
slider hung right in the heart of the
zone and
kepler does a nice job of getting the
barrel to it and as hard as kansas city
had to work for their one run
with one swing of the bat right there
this is how the twins can get you now
hunter dozier struck out swinging his
first time up there you go
[Music]
dozier gets it up the left field line
and down into the corner so that slider
appeared to be down but it was in one
away in the fifth and now buxton
buxton to short center and that'll die
for a base hit
and he's aboard hit his ball in the
first inning about as hard as he could
and that one not so much but it's a base
head he has a home run and he's reached
on an air by wit at second base
a high fly
to deep right center field
and buxton can walk home
polanco hits his second of the day
and another
2-2
home run all six twins hits have come
today with two strikes
some home runs and
you don't have to steal a bag when you
just get to jog around when the guy
behind you hits the ball that far
completely missed location right here
fastball center cotton a good hitting
team like the twins
[Music]
aren't going to let that one fly and
that ball got up into the second deck
donaldson trying to
join the party three strikeouts
for the hole and through donaldson
puts the ball in play and gets a base
hit a one out single kepler with a fly
ball home run and walk
high fly
right center field and deep
taylor olivares and it's off the wall
donaldson
had to hold up at second he'll gain
third base and kepler has a double off
the scoreboard
and there is ball four so now they're
loaded up and cave will have a chance to
break things wide open here bases loaded
for jake cave
and into right center field of base
heads
donaldson and kepler will both score and
cave drops in a two-run single
and it's eight to one
vet one for three in the ball game
snap baton a little lower but in a good
spot you talk about a seeing eye single
and the runner cave at second didn't
realize there's nobody at third base
that's to left
cave is back and leaps and makes a nice
catch on the warning track
[Applause]
jk with a long retreat and a nice
jumping catch at the end
fly ball center field
and the twins bounce back with a win
tonight 9-2 over kansas city
you